Sometimes there are ESLint
settings that are specific to a
single file rather than being
project or global settings. We
want these things to only be
specific to the file, or
sometimes even the lines that we
are working with. Sometimes
you have a setting where you're
like, "There's no way around
this for me, so I need to
temporarily turn off that
setting so I'm able to commit,"
or sometimes you have an
external library where they are
introducing global variables.
Let's take a look at globals
first, and then we'll go in
through other settings. If
you have ever used Twitter or
Google Analytics or Facebook,
you know that the way that they
work is they put a global
variable in your window, like GA
is for Google Analytics, and if
you want to use Google Analytics
you just start using the
function. But if we did it
like this, GA.track or whatever
the function is, like or
Twitter's is TWTTR.
trackConversion. If we start to
use these things, and we were to
ESLint our code, you know that
we get these two things here. GA
and Twitter are not defined.
That's because nowhere else have
we actually defined them.
What we can do with that is set
globals inside of this specific
file. The way that you do that
is, you go to the top, you give
yourself a block comment and you
say, globals TWTTR and GA. Now
when I give that a save and
rerun, we no longer get those
errors because we've said these
are two global variables that
we're expecting to have inside
of our window, and they're no
longer going to error out.
You could do that as a global
setting, but I prefer to just do
it file by file and really just
turn them off exactly where you
need them. Let's take a look
at when you might want to turn
off an ESLint setting in an
entire file, or even just in a
couple of lines. To illustrate
this, I'm going to show you
something called .array.includes.
This is part of ES2016 or ES7.
If we want to use this in our
projects, because it's really
handy, we have to polyfill it.
We're going to learn all about
polyfills, but essentially the
way that it works is that if the
array.prototype does not have
includes method, we will just
add it to the prototype. Now in
general it's a no-no to modify
your prototype of the built-ins
like array, and number, and
string. However, if you're
trying to be future-friendly,
then you have to polyfill it, so
it'll work in all of the current
browsers, older browsers, and
then when the browser does
implement includes, we're going
to be in good shape. If I
were doing that, I would go
ahead and take this code and I
would paste that in here. I
would go back and rerun my
ESLint here. You see that? Oh my
goodness, we have so many errors.
First of all let's look at this
first one, array.prototype is
read only. Properties should not
be added. That's the no-extend-
native property. That makes
sense. You shouldn't be just
adding anything willy-nilly to
the actual prototype of the
array, but because this is a
standard agreed-upon method
that's going to be added, it's
actually fine to do it. What
we need to do is we can turn it
off entirely in the file. What
we do here is go back up here
and make ourself another comment.
We say ESLint-disable, and then
we say the actual rule that we
want to disable, no-extend-
native. If I say ESLint-disable
no-extend-native, give that a
save. Now we've got 19
errors here. If I rerun it again,
we should only have 18 errors,
good. What I just did there
is I disabled it for the entire
file, or all of the code that
comes after it. If this was a
big file, then I might not want
to disable for the entire file.
I might want to just disable it
for single line. I'll show you
how to do that next. Really,
what you should do is, "I know,
I know, I shouldn't be doing
this, but I'm just going to
disable it for this one line
here, and then the line right
after it, I'm going to enable
that rule right again." What
that does is it will stop it,
ignore that the error that is on
here, only ignore this error,
and then keep going so if I were
to do it anywhere else in this
file it would still yell at me.
I'm going to save it. It should
still give me 18 errors. There
we go, no problem there. However,
we got all kinds of different
errors here, and that's because
I just included this polyfill.
It's code that someone else
wrote, and while maybe I should
fix it, I know that it works
fine in there's no issue with it.
What we could do is just ignore
this entire block. The only way
we would do that is, rather than
just commenting out this one
line here, you go up and you
call ESlint-disable, then you
take that comment, and where it
ends you enable it again.
That will just ignore absolutely
every single rule in between
these two comments. If re-run
our ESLint code now, you see if
we get no errors because I've
ignored all the code in between
it. It's really helpful to be
able to ignore, either on a file
00 which we generally put them
in the top -- or line by line,
which we disable, then re-enable
it again. Then finally, if you
would like to just disable an
entire block, then you could do
that as well. It works the
other way around. If you have
the ESLint rule which you have
disabled by default, you can
enable them by for a couple
lines, if you'd like that
specific rule to kick in only
for a bit of...